angela mackle has been undertaking a
farewell tour before she steps down as
chancellor her latest stop was kiev to
meet with ukrainian president florida
mircilenski ukraine is a key german ally
but it is bitterly disappointed that
germany will soon open the north stream
2 gas pipeline linking it with russia it
runs parallel to an existing connection
but doubles its capacity kiev has always
argued that the pipeline makes no
economic sense and that russia wants to
isolate ukraine politically and
economically
chancellor angela melka's last visit to
kiev covered a lot of ground
the conflict in eastern ukraine and the
economy were important but it was
russia's nordstrom 2 gas pipeline that
took center stage
we considered this project exclusively
from the point of security a dangerous
geopolitical weapon of the kremlin
ukraine fears russia could cut off its
gas while keeping western europe
supplied
mackel said russia would face
consequences if that were to happen
we've made it clear that we will
advocate further sanctions within the
european framework if this suspicion
that the pipeline is being used as a
weapon is substantiated
mackel has tried to balance ukrainian
and russian interests but that has
frequently frustrated kiev
most analysts believe she pushed for eu
sanctions against moscow over its
annexation of crimea but then berlin
approved nordstream 2 which links russia
under the baltic sea with germany
the pipeline completely bypasses kiev
which would lose billions in annual
transit fees
ukrainian leaders hoped that u.s
pressure would stop the project but
president joe biden withdrew sanctions
after meeting malcolm last month
the chancellor has stressed germany's
special responsibility towards kiev but
for now no deal has yet been struck to
guarantee that
let's get more on this story now with
dw's nick connolly he joins us from kiev
hi nick
was there any progress made between
these two leaders on nordstrom 2.
there was surprisingly little movement
from either side uh volumizing making no
secret of his disappointment there
basically saying that the promises and
the compensation offered by germany in
return for this pipeline being completed
uh the attempt to sweeten the pill as it
were was too little too late and not
really tangible he said that that loss
of income for transit fees but the
bigger strategic issue that you know
russia could afford to destabilize
ukraine if it doesn't need ukraine's
pipelines to transport its gas to europe
that that was an immediate tangible cost
in the short term and that investments
in green energy or potential sanctions
should russia once again
be aggressive towards ukraine that was
all potentially unenforceable so really
um a pretty
pretty pretty gray pretty kind of chilly
response there and no sense that
ukrainian side was really
convinced by the arguments brought by
angela merkel and her team well we
mentioned nick that angela merkel is on
something of a farewell tour and she got
a warm public welcome from vladimir
putin in moscow on friday how did that
compare to the reception that she got in
kiev
i think this is all the question of
expectations uh in the case of russia
given what's happened over the last 10
years uh from crimea to donbass and now
the poisoning alexander navalny last
year i think the very fact that they're
still talking is deemed to be a success
here in kiev the expectations are much
higher as you send your introduction
ukraine and germany are essentially
allies i mean germany is one of the
biggest donors to ukraine angela merkel
invested lots of diplomatic capital and
time back in 2014-15 bringing those
negotiations uh into fruition making
sure that this country was stabilized so
the fact that it has ended on such a
chilly note that she didn't get a kind
of cozy farewell trip to kiev is all the
more surprising um but i think it's also
a question of tone i think the
ukrainians want more forthright support
less diplomatic caution uh more
willingness in berlin to call out russia
and maybe just essentially give
ukrainians a sense that they have their
back and that they are not somehow
balancing on the fence trying to kind of
uh play the intermediary between moscow
and and kiev so a disappointment there
but recognition still that angela merkel
is someone who always found time for
ukraine
dw's nick connolly reporting for us in
kiev good to talk to you
you